hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to who I know you were
all waiting with bated breath for me to
take this blue alien who looks a lot
like a World of Warcraft and rendre not
for an eye on a date and so that's
exactly what we're going to do except
I'm gonna find out if she has any unique
gifts that she likes hello no yes I
don't have any space stuff oh I wonder
what outfit I should change into no you
don't need to change into anything
Celeste you look fine just the way you
are with your boob window and all that
they actually took the boob window out
of wonder girl by the way that was a new
thing I remember I appreciate this one
more tonight holy ground a little bit no
you don't stand out at all even though
the entire midriff it's right down to
your crotchal region is a little bit
obvious but you know what hey I'm okay
with this I think what's the
functionality of that seriously it looks
like you forgot to zip it up after you
went to the bathroom oh well I'm gonna
stop complaining right now I know I am
from Earth and the world's greatest
lover human lover I love humans white
the lovely gift oh whoa
cool I worked out
standing sheep holy crap you like the
Blues Tony I had known you've been doing
the Blues long well I guess you are blue
so mix it yes I went on a successful
date with an alien I feel so
accomplished in my life I can go tell my
mom I'm anticipating our next date okay
well I find myself excitedly
anticipating our next midnight
rendezvous well then that went well Hey
well is it a costume bonanza I assuming
that this is normal for your species I'm
gonna go now before I forget the entire
ability to talk you why are you in my
room
uh anyway I'll go say hi Lola cuz I I
should be getting sleep - was that a
yawn did you just yawn why am I so
aroused by a yawn
not that it enough good morning
high-def camera why do you want to
travel I'm so sure I'm so sure baby
goldfish move back your goldfish okay
finally I can know the Momo I don't want
to give them oh I don't want to do the
mama I don't want to use the mobile you
a question hmm motivates you to get out
the more oh you know stuff and things
goals energy what a really advanced what
keeps me going in
one could see who's been a birthday my
birthday is February 23rd mm-hmm
I won't forget let's go on a date I'd
love to go on a date you sure you would
you know you would done as I've said to
the alien that I met through the weird
device that I got from giving a ferry a
dirty magazine I am the world's greatest
human lover love that fresh morning as
far as I know you're human and therefore
love oh I'm done okay I did it I'm so
good at dates I wasn't even paying
attention I still won
you're welcome lady you welcome join you
oh yeah it was fun they need I can't
wait go on it again with another lady I
mean uh you're the only one free Lola if
that is your name I hope it is okay I'm
gonna go now all right
four right embarrass myself more okay so
it's morning oh I got mission log I said
of course for the etherion sector in
search of a galactic crime lord rumored
to be hiding out there what do you do oh
is that what you're doing is that really
well then good luck hunting warlords
anyway I guess I should know what I'm
kind of what is it was it made you
approach me that funny knew it I can't
blame you though I didn't look good in
the universe you do look pretty good but
not that good stuff being so up your own
ass about it okay so I need to go to the
park who's at the bark who's at the park
no one's at the park god damn it no
one's at the park poop it's one morning
I guess there's still time there's still
time let's see you
so right now cues it three bellies at
four so if I hit a cue have a good day
not from the Q continuum but QQ I will
be able to swing by the park next and
then hopefully meet up with Lola later
Here I am here maybe I am here it is me
here is the one that is me do you want a
pocket vibe man I'm definitely gonna get
a lot of mileage out of this one do shut
up do you want to go on a date except
wait this is from one of the most
intense matches I've ever had I didn't
win but at least I was cuter than her oh
you do look adorable I forgot that you
like tennis I thought you were all about
air travel anyway goodbye time to go on
a third date hope to see how much you've
improved I've improved a ton what did I
show you last time my penis
again with the mage spell pretty nice I
need to water my meat oh it's real it's
a real leaf bikini I didn't know this I
thought of course why wouldn't it be
real thousand I knew I got the moves
baby what I'm doing okay come on when
you say things like that it just makes
me feel bad I'm not a little boy I'm not
ooh Park yes Tiffany come rescue me from
my life of monotony and give me a cat
girl I should not shout things like that
but whatever shut up
feels good to be done with classes for
the day sure does now if I recall
correctly what I need to do is I need to
take this back go fish and toss it out
there and then I need to not go on a
date with you because I need leave and
then Momo's gonna say hi but I'm gonna
go say hi to belly after this no matter
what in case it's die did something
wrong bye bye but I sure did
okay holy Frick I just just go in your
washing machine it's so useful I really
like the high setting Oh Maggie ready
yep okay Matt that's that's a sensor
that's a one two sensor Matt get do it
alright thank you Matt will do this I'm
throwing on a date with a cat why am I
going on a date with a cat why why am I
doing this it's so pretty up here thanks
for taking me here don't don't make
noises like that I'm trying to
concentrate
shut up here we go
I did
I went on a date with a cat
well balli save me belly ballet
Momo's loyal servant outfit oh I forgot
I haven't even been exploring like the
outfits or anything collection loyal
servant oh that one well alrighty then
why not why not I don't know a lot I
just got a puppy know about how much you
do less cats being human too much a lot
30% wanna leave no goodbye forever I'm
going to see belly and then we're gonna
have a lovely date and it's going to end
with the dance of the sexy clothes
that's what's going to happen and no one
will say otherwise to me or else I shall
punch them in their dicks but there's
only women's game to up I won't do that
all night tonight
it won't be faithful later here comes
the creep of liar okay want to go on the
date baby anything man no point wasting
money on you now it's like sure my video
Lisa if you're like my to be a want to
drive it Princess Jasmine
I just want rewatched the Aladdin's told
all of the elapsed every Aladdin there
was and that's no joke I did nice yes
alright not a cat and I did it I like
how I'm totally fine with an alien but a
cat that crosses the line don't have
anywhere else to be tonight if you
wanted to hey you're taller than me oh
look I had the door I perfectly fine yes
yes this is very good intercourse look I
forgot how uh-huh oh yes I've got it the
sounds were I love when we have sex in
this computer game
give me the penis' oh god Matt censor
Jesus I forgot that happened man man I
love all right then this is the most
uncomfortable I've ever been let's just
get this over with why am i dragging
this out do it do it do it do it do it
do it do it better a little more it
looked ok oh we did it
mark sent by give me the virtual wiener
slap once more slapped me in the face
with your virtual reader mark Oh God
Wow jeez um okay alright then you guys
don't see what's going on there but Wow
uh I forgot she was yoga instructor I
forgot that she was flexible okay all
right then well I'm gonna need a cold
shower after this well alright then
we've made progress I'm so proud of my
life choices
you can say what I don't know I don't
even have words neither do i but not for
the same reason so that's the ended in
this this episode so thank you everybody
so much for watching in the next one
we'll have them even more uncomfortable
scenarios for all of us to experience at
the same time so thanks again that's
always I will see you in the next video
on the floor